that ground game maybe that small ground
game you know a lot of that market went
to russia do you know that
about the hamster a lot of hamster
gerbils g pigs will you look them up
maybe nick the roborovskies
the rubber it's a
i don't know if it is family
not it became a family business the
hamster business but the roborosk is a
lot of that market russian dwarf
hamsters oh when i was young they were
straight american man i mean you got
them right here how do you know the
difference between a russian hamster and
an american hamster a lot of it's in the
width the i don't want to say the thigh
gap but it's like the width of their
legs how far apart they are from how far
apart their their legs are yeah so do uh
russian uh hamsters have bigger nuts uh
i wouldn't say bigger nut uh actually
maybe that's why they have that extra
space there what do you mean the legs
are just further apart but nothing is
filling it more it's just more space the
legs are a little bit further apart now
if you get those roboroskis or those
white a lot of the dwarf hamster
businesses come out of russia they're
over there in basements they're dark art
and brother they're doing it all
you know i'm surprised that's a syrian
that's a syrian hamster oh it is no the
the left is an american hamster the
right is a roboski russian hamster
see the robots putting his hands
together he's plodding you see how
they're doing howie
you know what's weird that you're
showing me these things that i'm really
into it but you talk about them like
like if i go to a jeweler and i want to
buy like a stone or a diamond for my no
this is the roborowski crystal and it's
got an an incline cut and it's got a
clarity of six you talk about hamsters
in the same way as a jeweler talks about
diamonds oh these are gems baby these
are uh so what are they shipping these
here illegally i wouldn't say illegally
i don't think that i mean i don't know
what they were doing at the time but
when i was young it was all american
hampshire you picked up a hamster you
could hear leonard skinner you know or
you could hear barbra streisand
but now stand you could hear yeah barbra
streisand yeah not fiber style sand you
could hear both of them if you wanted or
is barbara streich stand a place where
you went to go buy roborovski's oh at
the barber strike stand at the bribe
people who need roberstrovsky are the
luckiest people in the world yeah
you know what's great i love that you
come up with something and then your
producer nick has to like with a not
even a smile just a serious look is
searching the web for the roboroski
dwarf hamster breeding look at him i
mean but it seems like it's the dwarf
hamsters roborovskies they're from
russia it seems to be like a dark arts
like a
there seems to be something
uh evil sinister right
and if you look at a man armor when i
was young there was a the smaller
hamsters the stores were selling they
were fuller they had a little bit more
life in them you looked like maybe after
school after after the day at the pet
shop they went home to loving families
you know they had dinner at a small
table but you look at these roborovskies
man it looked like they doing cigarettes
they're
you know they're sleeping on stacked you
know sleeping all on you know a lot of
groups in one bed this is horribly sad
we should get uh
is there somebody like sarah mclachlan
that could sing a song about the russian
hamsters
in the small arms of the angels
and you have all these russian hamsters
just looking really sad you should put
together a video
that wouldn't be a bad idea it would for
a dollar a day yeah you can
lessen that
how much does it cost to feed a hamster
a day what do hamsters eat i bet a dime
a lot of them usually eat like a mix
they'll eat like a uh i'm gonna bring it
up next you have one everything i ask
nick has the answer to yeah bring up
that hand food mix daddy do you
do you own a hamster i don't have any
right now man the last thing i had was
two big g pigs baby
uh what is the difference between a
guinea pig and a hamster the difference
between the guinea pig and the hamster
most of all the size
between their legs no i think overall oh
that's i mean the russian versus yeah
that's russian versus american is
definitely it's a it's a kind of a
you got a heartier kind of uh
what is it called the bottom of a car
chassis yeah yeah you gotta you got a
wider chassis on is that what they're
referred to in the hamster world or the
g world or that what what's the gerbil
yeah gerbil or gerbil some people call
him daddy gerbil and nazi wasn't he
yeah gerbil general gerbil was a nazi
you're asking
i think he was he was well i don't think
look him up
look up
lieutenant goebbel nazi gerbil nazi
gerbil there he is there he is joseph
gerbil
joseph gerbil he was a not tall damn
there he was yeah yeah no it's a famous
you don't that's why i've never been
able to be comfortable around gerbils oh
really i could see that's a little furry
adorable nazi and i don't want them in
my house they're walking like this i'm
sure it's a little dicey right and every
time i open the oven they would
i get excited
start they start clapping yeah so i have
to is that bad
i mean it's cancel look that's no cereal
that's factual okay that is factual
that's factual and you know we must
never forget yeah oh right okay that's
we must never forget fur should be a pet
shop i love that
wow
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one